rick and morty season five has caused a
little divide in the rick and morty
community recently
some issues have started to arise with
the newest season that is starting to
slightly hinder the show for this video
i wanted to go through them and
determine what is wrong with season five
of rick and morty and i'm not saying if
the show is bad or anything i'm just
critiquing a great show that is starting
to show some flaws
so for the first aspect out of 5 i'll go
into the most simple one which is the
lack of the rick and morty pairing to me
in the earlier seasons this is one of
the core aspects of the show that made
it work so well because a duo of rick
and morty was so intriguing and it had a
lot of depth the best part of their
pairing is always the tension between
the two of them and how marty is
challenged by rick which forces him to
change as a character but for season 5
there's only two episodes so far that
have that pairing in most of the run
time one of them being rick dependent
spray which didn't really have the best
writing and was everyone's least
favorite episode and the other being
exploitation spectacular and in that
episode a lot of time is spent between
the pairing of rick and the president so
again we don't have that traditional
pairing throughout in which we go into
the complexities of rick and morty's
relationship
to contrast this with a perfect episode
that has this pairing is the vat of acid
here rick comes up with what morty
classifies as a stupid idea and he
thinks that rick is losing his touch
which that on its own opens up a lot of
funny passive dialogue and it also leads
into a point of conflict in which morty
is mad at rick for not taking his ideas
seriously
this turns into the classic sequence of
morning living life with a respawn
button but in turn that teaches morty
that living life without consequences is
unfulfilling
then rick takes it a step further and
introduces that there were in fact
consequences with a mind-bending twist
this is an example of what i would
classify as peak rick and morty we have
crazy sci-fi concepts interwoven with
great character building however when
you look at season 5 the weight of the
new sci-fi concepts and their impact are
lessened because they don't really
affect our characters that much
with the inclusion of the whole family
in more episodes or adding in more
characters it's hard to get down to a
personal and more detailed level
and this brings me to my next point
which is it feels like there's a lack of
meaningful character development or
lasting changes that happens to the
primary characters
let's use morty as the main example
throughout season 5 because he generally
changes the most in the show the first
episode is mostly fine and is one of the
best episodes morty doesn't really
change in it but he does go through a
badass journey in a convenient mort
morty dates planet tina and during their
breakup he ends up in a dark abyss of
depression
however this has already been done
before in the vative acid episode in
which he loses the love of his life when
joe reverts morty back to his prior
checkpoint and morty gets so depressed
that he kills himself on repeat which is
very dark and to me is done better than
planet tina
also the fact that morty's more
depressed mindset doesn't carry over
between episodes really downplays the
importance of his breakup it makes it
seem meaningless when at the start of
the next episode morty seems completely
fine
if there was more continuity i feel like
it would help the characters be more
dynamic instead of just reverting back
to their normal state because in season
1 and 2 morty changes throughout those
seasons but in the later seasons it
feels like morning is in more of a
default state of being more hardened and
independent
the only episode for season five in
terms of character development that i
think is really good is rectannal
friendshine of the spotless mort in
which rick tries to save his best friend
bird person
it really shows how dedicated rick is
towards people he cares about while
simultaneously showing how selfish she
is at the end
and it also helps that this episode
expands the lore quite a bit while
moving the bird person subplot forward i
know we can't have this type of
development all the time but what i
really want is more connections and
carryovers between episodes so that any
character or story development is more
relevant and not most of the season
being comprised of one offs
for the next aspect of what's wrong with
season 5 we have pacing
and by that i mean that the pacing for
some of the episodes is way too fast i
don't have this problem with the earlier
seasons but now some of the episodes
feel like they are rushing through
dialogue jokes or just rapidly going
from crazy moment to crazy moment
without giving enough breathing room
the best example of this is in
wreck-dependent spray during the
build-up to the climax of the episode we
quickly go from getting captured by
morty sperm getting saved by sticky
revealing that the sperm are heading
towards the human egg the twist revealed
that it will make an incest baby because
it's summer's egg to then randomly
getting captured by cannibalistic horse
people and this all happens in 3 minutes
you would think that would take place
over about 10 minutes but 3 minutes is
straight up a breakneck pace it becomes
overloading very quickly when going
through that much material in that short
amount of time that and without a slower
pace most of the jokes and dialogue
don't have enough time to land because
the characters are quickly moving on to
something else or just being interrupted
by something
another episode with rush pacing is that
thanksplication spectacular i won't list
out everything that happens but in terms
of plot and story events the episode is
so ambitious to the point that in order
to fit the entire story into a 20 minute
time slot the pace has to move extremely
fast the overall turkey takeover is a
fun concept but the episode is way too
packed full of plot points for its own
good if the episode was longer and was
instead 30 to 40 minutes then the pace
wouldn't need to be rushed to fit
everything into a 20 minute format
also this issue of pacing doesn't apply
to every episode in season 5 and some of
them do take their time like rick turner
friendshine to me that is one of the
better episodes because the full 20
minutes is directly focused on one
simple objective which is saving bird
person which from there that simple
concept can then blossom into a more
complex episode without it feeling
overwhelming
unlike the exploitation and rick
dependent spray where there's a constant
rotation of different objectives and
obstacles to the point of it becoming
tiring
on to the next aspect we have rick being
written to be more underpowered
due to each episode being written by a
different writer some of the writers
make it to where rick is conveniently
weaker than what he should be to justify
conflict within an episode a good
example of this is rick's intelligence
there are two instances where the
driving conflict is because rick didn't
notice something that he should have
like in the giltron episode rick clearly
took out the anime people and stole
their mechs and later on in the episode
he chooses to trust the anime people he
betrayed more than his own family
which leads to rick getting betrayed and
the fact that he didn't see that coming
or was a part of some kind of plan of
his is pretty infuriating given how
smart he used to be
you can argue that he made those
mistakes because he was drunk but rick
was drunk throughout the first season
and he never came across as being that
stupid he does make mistakes every now
and then like in rick potion but that
wasn't a very difficult field of
knowledge of making a complicated
antidote meanwhile in giltron he makes
an obvious mistake of trusting people
that are clearly untrustworthy then we
also have the incense and rick
dependence prey in which warney
successfully lies to rick about his
sperm being in the horse sperm container
in the moment rick notices that
something is weird about morty stopping
him from checking its horse sperm but he
just doesn't think anything of it
maybe this moment would work if the
audience didn't know that morty sperm
was in there and this was a small detail
that we also missed along with rick
but since we know that information we
expect rick to figure it out and to have
a revelation that this has been a funny
lesson for morty all along
instead of being shocked and not knowing
that it was clearly morty's sperm
or even a smaller example where rick is
clearly being taken advantage of by this
hot alien while summer is constantly
telling him that to then rick still
getting surprised that he got betrayed
this goes into the territory of
contrived writing due to rick doing
things or acting in a manner that is out
of character just for events in the
story to happen and i find it funny that
dan harmon even admitted this in an
interview for inside the episode the
episode starts with the heaviest amount
of contrivance in the in the world by
the way this is just the intelligent
side of the coin because rick has also
become underpowered in terms of solving
problems like him getting saved by mr
nimbus when all his weapons were taken
away and to make up for that there was a
funny fourth wall break joke but then we
also have rick getting outsmarted by
morty's sperm and also having to get
saved by it getting saved by a random
horse lover which also results in him
controlling the horses conveniently
getting outsmarted by the president when
he identified them as undercover turkeys
to then getting saved by the president
two minutes later and then they even
copy the joke from the first episode of
rick losing his weapon since he was a
turkey for too long
i can go on but rick seems to be nerfed
so that other characters can take the
spotlight but while doing so rick loses
some of his charm from the earlier
seasons
he used to be an uncontrolled badass who
didn't need anyone and was smart enough
and strong enough to overcome any
obstacles that came at him sure every
now and then an obstacle is overcome in
a silly way or through a manner of deus
ex mocking a mechanics but that still
builds him up as being a godlike force
to be reckoned with
and i know that you need to limit your
heroes to challenge them at times but a
lot of recent instances has been rick
getting saved by other people instead of
him creatively solving the problems
like rick getting saved by a giant
incest baby but then even in the same
season we have recreatively solving the
problem of hurting the demons in hell
so the inconsistency in writing is very
apparent this season which also leads
into the next point which is we have a
writing team that's almost entirely new
for this point i'm not saying that the
writing in rick morty is bad now but in
some episodes the quality seems to take
a bit of a dive for example the four
lowest rated episodes of the season and
even the entire show are written by
writers who have written very little for
the show before
and that probably is not a coincidence
but yeah there are no more writers that
are remaining from the first three
seasons
like one of the best writers for the
show mike mcmahon who is responsible for
writing the rickshank redemption name
total rickhall has left and moved on to
being a creator for different shows
and this is the case for all the regular
writers of the earlier seasons
as to why they left there could be
multiple reasons but it probably
revolves around money but going back to
the quality of season 5 i don't think
the newer writers have as good as an
understanding as the original writers
did the breakneck pacing issues with
character development character pairings
concept development and other small
writing mistakes like it being contrived
at times didn't used to be that big of
an issue all of these flaws aren't that
massive to really call the show bad or
even mediocre really it just makes the
show feel not as good as it once was
sure there are some flaws but there's
still a lot to like and hopefully the
last two episodes are going to be great
since they're taking a hiatus for them
and i'm also making this video before
they come out overall though i just
wanted to make this video to point out
some of the flaws i have with season 5.
if none of these flaws bother you then
that's completely fine but regardless
though i hope you enjoyed the video and
let me know in the comments what you
think about season 5 of rick and morty
you